Isn't it their right? Isn't that that
Isn't it the nation's right to say,
"Okay, we only want X amount because we
don't want for whatever reason we don't
want our demography to be overwhelmed in
10, 20 a right. I would say no, I would
say it's not a right. It's a genuine
difference of opinion. And that's the
same reason I'm against Jim Crow laws.
I'm saying if you're interested in
demography preserving demography, well,
that's how people sounded during Jim
Crow era. They said, "Hey, if we allow
Here's the thing. I think people like
you as- assume that the people who do
this are all white. Blacks, browns, and
yellows do the same thing. If you told
them, "Hey, we're going to introduce a
boatload of whites to the point where
you're going to become maybe a
minority," blacks, browns, and yellows
would resist it even more so. And you
think that It's not a racial thing. It's
just a human thing. This is our country.
We want it our way, our culture, and our
people. That's just the world. It's not
like a white racial thing.
>> It's definitely a white racial thing.
You have to look at the
cultural imperialism. You have to look
at the direct This is an important point
which I didn't realize if I said that,
but yeah, exactly. So, there you go. So,
here's a point. A lot of what he's
complaining about it's not that it
doesn't happen or doesn't or or isn't
real or isn't or Europeans don't do
this. It's that everyone does it and
usually on a much worse scale, much more
savage and violent scale. So, it's so
hypocritical for him to just, you know,
harp on Europe, America, the West as if
Africa doesn't think the same way, South
America, Asia doesn't think the same
way, the Islamic world doesn't think the
same way. Everyone has borders. Everyone
has laws. Everyone wants to maintain
their demographic integrity and their
socio-political
governmental structure without being
inundated by illegal immigrants. And yet
he thinks this is something that only
white people do cuz they're racist.
Meanwhile, everyone else embraces it and
cuz everyone gets along and they're not
imperialistic and you know, everyone
holds hands and sings Kumbaya. Okay, I
think in many ways this is one of his
biggest issues. He doesn't seem to
understand this. This is part of the
woke virus. Again, you know, I write a
lot and I make videos about fake history
as I call it. And the number one issue
with fake history it's not that what
they're teaching you is fake, it's that
they present it in a vacuum, okay? So,
they talk about imperialism. Look what
Europe did for a hundred years between,
I don't know, uh you know, 1800 to
1930s, 50s, a little over a hundred
years, but they never ever ever seem to
realize that, "Oh, those brown and black
and yellow people did 10 times worse for
a thousand years, okay?" And I think at
one point he said something about,
"Well, the reason people go to Europe is
because of what Europeans did and
Americans." You know, Americans and
Europeans, imperialism and colonialism
and wars, that's what ruined those
countries. Uh no, sorry. Most of those
countries were worse before Europe
meddled with them, okay? If anything,
the ones the the ones that Europe
actually meddled with more were better
and lasted longer. Algeria in northern
Africa just made a law. Algiers, the
capital, the city in Algeria, it had the
biggest slave emporium where Europeans
were enslaved and brought to North
Africa, enslaved by Muslims from North
Africa, brought to Algiers and sold to
the Muslim world. It was a massive
emporium. At least 1.25
million Christians, Europeans, were sold
through there in the 16th century. And
this is to say nothing about the
millions in the centuries before or
after. This is just one of the most
well-documented ones. But these Barbary
pirates as they're known went to Iceland
and so forth. Now, here's the situation
we're in. Algeria later, after
terrorizing Europe for centuries and
being these pirates, France colonized
it, which is to say France, the Franks,
the Crusaders finally, after the
thousand 400 year or 1200 year war at
that point, had reached a climax. Now,
the Franks are back against the Muslims
and they're colonizing them, which means
whatever bad things you want to think,
but a lot of good things.
Infrastructure, governance, medicine,
technology, progress, literacy. That's
what the European colonialists brought,
all right? The other people, including
Barbary and Algiers and Muslims, when
they invaded and colonized, you know
what they brought? Death, destruction,
and slavery. And that's it. And they
wiped out everyone and they left, okay?
So, were the Europeans evil for
colonizing? Okay, if you want, whatever,
but in comparison to what Muslims and
non-Muslims, non-Europeans did, at least
they brought something decent with them,
something good, where Muslims never did.
Bring back the fire. Bring back the
fire. Bring back the fire and the
righteous name. Bring back the fire.
Bring back the fire and the righteous
name. Bring back the fire. Bring back
the fire and the righteous name. Bring
back the fire. Bring back the fire and
the righteous name. Bring back the fire.
Bring back the fire and the righteous
name. Bring back the fire. Bring back
the fire and the righteous name. Bring
back the fire. Bring back the fire and
the righteous name. Bring back the fire.
Bring back the fire and the righteous
name. Bring back the fire. Bring back
the fire and the righteous name. Bring
back the fire. Bring back the fire and
the righteous name. Bring back the fire.
Bring back the fire and the righteous
name.